- Feel like I heard you
started in weddings, right?
Singing weddings?
- I did weddings and bar mitzvahs.
- I did too!
I did, I'm not even Jewish!
(laughing)
I did bat mitzvahs, bar mitzvahs,
I did all that.
I did funerals, have
you ever done a funeral?
It's the worst thing you've
ever done in your life.
(laughing)
- I lied about my age 'cause I thought
people wouldn't hire me,
so I said I was 18,
as though that was any better to be out
with a bunch of 35 year
old men after hours,
at midnight singing.
I'd drive around illegally in Long Island,
'cause if you had a junior license,
so you're not supposed to
be driving at that time.
I knew all the--
- The cops are actually here,
to talk to you about it.
(laughing)
I'm just kidding.
So one time this guy had a heart attack
while I was singing, on the dance floor.
It's not funny, I'm sorry.
I don't mean to laugh.
- That happened to me in Australia!
- That happened to you?
It's so freakin' weird.
- Yes!
And my band leader was kind of mean,
was like cracking the whip,
he was like, "The show goes on!
You keep singing!"
And I was like, "But he's
sick, we have to stop!"
and he made me keep singing.
And then the bride came over,
and she was like, "You're so insensitive!
Stop singing!"
I was just crying, and I went
over to the Viennese table
and started stuffing my
face with chocolate eclairs.
- This is the worst!
- Just like prayed for this man.
He ended up being okay, but.
- Oh, my Gosh.
(audience clapping)
That's the worst story!
Oh, my God.
It does suck though,
when you're doing a show,
and all of a sudden you're like,
what's happening over
there, and you have no idea,
and you feel insensitive.
It's not that, you just didn't even know.
You have in ears in and all that.
- And another time these
kids in the bar mitzvah,
they were throwing food
at me and my friend,
we were singing.
We're singing like,
♪ I'm so excited ♪
or whatever, and they
were throwing food at us.
And finally we'd just had had it,
so we threw back this chocolate sundae,
and we ran into the bathroom
and we were in the bathroom
just hiding in there.
Nobody knew.
The band leader was like,
where are those girls,
we need them to sing.
The little kids were outside the door
waiting to smash whipped
cream on our heads.
- I need you to start a podcast
of just random stories about your life.
- Wedding and bar mitzvah stories.
- Like, what?
Those two stories were gems.
- That's where I got my education,
and just getting a thicker
skin, and performing,
and kinda going with whatever happens.
You have that, you're so in the moment.
- I've done some weird stuff.
I've never had food
thrown at me, God bless.
(laughing)
I'm not nice like you.
I would've not handled that well.
(laughing)
I'd have taken my earrings off.